Oh, wait, I set it up so fast that I forgot to do a loading screen.
Wait, am I live?
Maybe I am.
Am I live?
Oh, I am.
Oh!
I was like, setting everything up so fast, I was like...
That I forgot to do a loading screen.
My bad.
Sorry.
Hello, welcome.
Oh, let me tweet too.
It's gonna be not such a long stream.
I don't know if you can hear it.
The Omnicord.
I'm gonna have to adjust my mic.
I should probably do a double mic setup for this, now that I think about it.
Never saw an Omnicord before.
Cool, I'm glad that I can be maybe your first experience with it then.
It is very neat looking, right?
It's actually from the 80s, so it's quite a trooper for living.
Hold on, let me actually try and do a double mic setup.
Let me try that real quick, I've never tried it before.
I have my other mic out.
I should have been more prepared.
I lied, I don't have my mic out.
Why did I say that?
I have my other mic out.
I don't, I put it away.
I literally cleaned up earlier.
What should we play, guys?
We can play anything that we want.
Here, I'll even... I'll do some silly stuff too.
I'm getting it together.
Laughs in before the 80s, what do you mean by that?
I'm going to plug this in.
Tell me if you hear me in my other mic.
Actually, hold on, I'm going to turn off my mic so it doesn't pop.
Whoa, oh my gosh, so crisp.
Hello, wow.
This is my other mic, let me move some stuff around.
I will set up... it's very loud.
I think so, it's not really set up very much.
I use this mic for recording vocals for songs.
It almost has become like an ASMR.
But it's not ASMR, we're doing Omnicore.
Give me a second, I didn't prepare for... I just had this idea on a whim.
So I was like, I'll just set it up really fast.
That's exactly, you were getting the behind the scenes of the setup.
And everything.
I'm going to put this mic...
And then, hold on, now if I talk like this, it's like I'm talking into both.
I don't know if you can tell, actually.
Okay, let me grab my Omnicore.
And, okay.
Sounds amazing, maybe I should switch to this mic then.
For like normal streams.
No, it's too...
It's too...
They're in sync, yeah, they're in sync.
I feel like it's too crisp, maybe.
Alright, I'm going to put this mic, right?
Sorry, sorry.
Oh wait, if I point it down, the mic is going to fall out.
Hold on, I'm trying to figure this out.
One moment, please.
Can you explain what an Omnicore is?
Yeah, I can try.
I can do my bestie.
Because...
Sorry if you can hear that, I'm like sliding it into the mic holder.
It's this little contraption that you see down here.
I don't even know how much to describe it though, because...
Basically, it's like, you see all these buttons?
They're cords.
So, here, I'll play some for you.
Sorry, sorry, the mic slipped out of the...
Okay, this mic holder is not working.
Sorry if you heard that, I'm sorry.
You hear that?
So, it just plays kind of like, you can change.
And then, the slider that you see on the, I guess, your left...
When I slide it like that, just with my finger, it works.
Just like that.
It's very like, light taps and stuff.
Like that, like that.
And it plays it.
Just like, it's so...
It's so cute.
I know, right?
It's very, very cute.
I'm still trying to figure out a way, because currently I'm holding...
I'm currently holding the second mic, and so...
I need to figure out a way to...
To be able, because I need to be able to use both hands to switch between chords.
Maybe if I put it, like, in my lap.
Let's see.
Like so.
On top of the speaker.
I think that works.
So some of you guys might be familiar with this instrument already, and you don't even realize, because it was common in Adventure Time.
Hold on, I'm making sure, if I move my thigh, it doesn't...
Sounds a bit like Steven Universe.
Same musician?
Wait, why did I just type Adventure Time?
Hold on, I'm not gonna have you guys listen to that.
Let's see.
And if you ever get one...
You can always, if you're just like, oh, I wanna play this, but I don't, you know...
You can follow guitar chords, and it kind of works the same way, which is pretty neat.
So I'm gonna warm up, I suppose.
Hold on, I'm gonna...
Attempt this.
I wish I could find a good way to hold it.
Sorry if it keeps going in and out.
I'm so sorry, guys.
I should've set this up better.
Let me try just like this.
It's resting on my booby mouse pad.
Can you hear that okay?
That's good.
Turn it up a little.
I won't be singing super duper loud, I think, so...
I have to warm up, sorry.
But I'm losing myself, and I'm afraid you're gonna lose me, too This magic keeps me alive, but it's making me crazy And I need to save you, but who's going to save me?
Please forgive me for whatever I do When I don't remember you Marceline, I can feel myself slipping away I can't remember what it made me say But I remember that when I saw you frown I swear it wasn't me, it was the crown
This magic keeps me alive, but it's making me crazy And I need to save you, but who's going to save me?
Please forgive me for whatever I do When I don't remember you Please forgive me for whatever I do When I don't remember you That's like a warm-up song, sorry Here, I'll do something silly now
I'll do something silly now for you guys Play All-Star, that's a good one, too
Oh, sorry, sorry, okay, let's do this one, too I've never done this one before, so...
Baby, can't you see I'm calling?
Why is it all A minor, my, like you should wear a warning?
It's dangerous, I'm falling
There's no escape, I can't wait I need a hit, baby, give me it You're dangerous, I'm loving it
Too high, can't come down This doesn't feel right Loose in my head, spinning round and round Do you feel me now?
Why is it all A minor?
This is so strange With a taste of your lips, I wanna ride Where is that?
No You're toxic?
That doesn't sound right Under the taste of a poison paradise I'm addicted to you, don't you know that you're toxic?
And I love what you do, don't you know that you're toxic?
Yay, that was interesting.
Let's see.
Okay, I can try All Star too.
Somebody once told me the world is gonna roll me I ain't the sharpest tool in the shed But she was looking kinda dumb with her finger and her thumb in the shape of an L on her forehead Well, the years start coming and they don't stop coming Fed to the rules and I hit the ground running Didn't make sense not to live for...
Oh gosh, that scared me.
Oh my gosh, thank you.
Remember you?
I can do that one.
I'll do it after this.
Hit the ground running Didn't make sense not to live for fun Your brain gets smart but your head gets dumb So much to do, so much to see So what's wrong with taking the back streets?
You'll never know if you don't go You'll never shine if you don't glow Hey now, you're an all star What the hell does that mean?
Sorry.
Get your game on, go play Hey now, you're a rock star Get the show on, get paid All that glitters is... I don't know this note.
Only shooting stars break the mold It was like C-sharp-D-I-M I don't know what that means.
C-sharp-D-I-M What does that mean?
What kind of Omnicord do you have?
The same one that's on the screen, baby.
I don't exactly remember what model it is.
I'm sorry.
OM84
C -sharp but the fifth one is semitone lower.
Oh, diminished.
Cool.
I don't have C-sharp on here.
I just went to C-minor.
It's fine.
Whatever.
Let's see.
This is a sad song though.
Are you sure?
Wait, remember you.
That's what I did earlier.
Oh, I think it came late.
I'm sorry.
I think it was later.
I was thinking of the other one.
What's the other Adventure Time song?
Adventure Time guitar chords.
Yeah, the notes are backed up.
Sorry.
Oh, Everything Stays.
Is it okay if I play that one?
Will you guys be too sad?
lol
Whoa, that's not at all.
Sorry.
That was terrible.
lol
lol So slight, slightly, daily and nightly, in little ways, when everything stays.
Sorry, I feel like my hand is blocked because I have my hand over the slider.
It's kind of covering the speaker.
So I'm sorry if it's making it muffled a little bit.
Let's see, what else can we play?
What's another...
Live concert where you play the Omnicord?
The people need... wait, Chara!
I mean, maybe... Astro Girl, are you guys okay?
Do you just want to let it all out?
I don't even know, hold on.
No, it's okay.
It's okay to not be okay.
Life is tough.
Even afterlife can be tough sometimes.
But you know, just take it one day at a time.
It'll be okay, you know?
I don't think this is the right chord.
Starlight, you shine.
Illuminate the sky.
The endless...
Hold
on, let me try a different... Maybe I can find a different chord.
Oh, maybe this.
I think this probably goes with like a...
I can't get it right though.
Sorry, I'm not so musically inclined to be able to... Oh wait, maybe this starts from the beginning.
Oh no, it doesn't.
I really like this instrument though.
It's really pretty.
Okay.
Nope, that's not right.
These chords are so bad.
Oh, nope, sorry.
A little dream...
Sorry, there's a lot.
Sounds better.
Wait, no, I don't think that sounds good.
I keep saying A flat, or sorry, E flat, but I don't think it works.
Oh, yeah.
Ah, ah?
I don't have this chord.
Oh no.
Sorry.
I don't have it though.
I did say it was a practice room, okay?
I don't have it.
Ureshii koto kanashii koto mo zenbu
Yay.
Sorry, that was so scuffed.
Miyu, thank you for the okajoubaru.
Thank you.
Thank you, thank you.
What else?
Oh, hold on.
Popular English songs.
Let's see.
What's another song?
That was great.
Thank you.
What's vanilla twilight?
What's that one?
Popular.
Ghostbusters.
That's a good one.
Wait, is it bad?
I don't know Ghostbusters' originals so much.
I only know Bustin'.
Let's see.
This is gonna sound terrible.
If there's something strange... Wait, it's not giving me any... Wait, why is it B?
If there's something strange... I don't think this works.
I don't think this works, you guys.
If there's something strange in your neighborhood, who are you gonna call?
Ghostbusters!
If there's something weird and it don't look good, who are you gonna call?
Oh wait!
I ain't afraid of no ghost.
If you're seeing things and you're running through your head, who are you gonna call?
Ghostbusters!
An invisible man sleeping in your bed.
Who are you gonna call?
Ghostbusters!
Coco.
Oh my goodness.
I could try.
You guys are really wanting to cry tonight.
Thank you.
Remember me.
No, I have to say goodbye.
Don't... Sorry.
Don't let it make you cry.
For even if I'm far away, I hold you in my heart.
Sorry, I'm so bad at this.
I sing a secret song to you each night.
We are apart.
Remember me.
No, I have to travel far.
Each time you hear a sad guitar, know that I'm with you the only way that I can be.
Until you're in my arms again.
Remember
me.
Yay!
Jeanette Juice by Snoop Dogg.
I don't know that.
I'm sorry.
Let's see.
Fight on the outside.
I'm trying to think of another pop song.
What's another pop song?
Clappy.
Thank you.
Indie Haven.
Everybody kind of has their own reasoning for things, you know?
Lips of an angel.
Our House by The Carpenters.
Sing?
Oh, wait.
What major?
Wait, what?
Hold on, maybe this one.
I think I hear it, actually.
No, I think I hear the other one better.
Wait, maybe I don't.
Sing a song.
Sing out loud.
Sing out.
Strong.
Sing of good things.
Not bad.
Sing of happy.
Not sad.
Sing.
Sing a song.
Make it simple.
To last your whole life.
Long.
Don't worry that it's not good enough.
For anyone else to hear.
Just sing.
Sing a song.
La.
La, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la.
La, la, la, la.
Wait, someone said Frank Sinatra.
Makes me want to throw my bandana into the ocean.
Figuring it out as we go.
Yep, pretty much.
Fly me to the moon.
And let me play among the stars.
Let me see what spring is like on Jupiter and Mars.
In other words, hold my hand.
In other words, baby, kiss me.
Fill my heart with song.
And let me sing forevermore.
You are all I long for.
All I worship and adore.
In other words, please be true.
In other words, I love you.
Wait, I tried to hit the high note.
I couldn't hit it.
I'm sorry.
We're around this.
It's as high as it goes.
Break stuff.
Oh my gosh, let's try it.
Break stuff guitar chords.
It's just one of those days when you don't want to wake up.
Everything is fucked, everybody sucks.
You don't really know why, but you want to justify.
Ripping someone's head off.
No human contact.
And if you interact, your life is on contract.
Your best bet is to stay away, motherfucker.
It's just one of those days.
It's all about the he says, she says bullshit.
I think you better quit letting shit slip.
Or you'll be leaving with a fat lip.
It's all about the he says, she says bullshit.
I think you better quit talking that shit.
Punk, so come and get it.
Wait.
Get it.
How are you pressing the right chords?
I don't know.
Stronger than you.
I don't know that one.
Wait.
Stronger than you.
Steven.
Sorry.
Universe.
I could do the opening though.
I'll try and learn it for next time.
But I can do...
Let's see.
Pinto-chan, kawaii.
Arigatou.
Where's the chorus?
Of what?
Break stuff?
That is the chorus.
It's all about the he says, she says...
That's it.
Beyond the sea.
I'll do that one after this.
Hold on.
Beyond the sea.
I'll do that song.
I don't have that much time.
So I'll do that one last.
And I'll do this one.
And then beyond the sea.
What?
Why does it sound so weird?
Why do I...
Why do I feel like I'm not getting it right?
Sorry, it doesn't sound very great.
Maybe it's not...
Hold on, let me try this one instead.
Nope, it's giving me the same one.
Maybe I think it's right.
It's true, cause I think you're so good And I'm nothing like you Look at you go I just adore you I wish that I knew What makes you think I'm so special If I could begin to do Something that does right by you I would do about anything I would even learn how to love When I see the way you look Shaken by how long it took.
I could do about anything.
I could even learn how to love like you.
Love like you.
Love me like you.
Sorry, I can't get it right at all.
Sounds like the keys don't match.
I know, it didn't sound right to me.
I was just doing what they...
Maybe I'm remembering it wrong.
Oh well, I tried.
I could do it in karaoke.
Somewhere...
Beyond the sea...
Sea...
Somewhere...
Oh my gosh, there's so many...
Waiting for me...
My lover stands on golden sands...
And watches the ships that go sailing.
Wow, thank you so much for the 50 gifts.
Guys, I don't know about this one.
There's so many chords, I can't tell where to change at for me.
I'll make it be comfortable.
Beyond the sea...
Sea...
Somewhere...
Beyond the sea...
Waiting for me...
My lover...
Stands on golden sands...
Sanders, not sands.
And watches the ships...
That go sailing...
I can't get it.
Somewhere...
Beyond the sea...
She's there...
Watching for me...
If I could fly...
Like birds on...
High...
And straight to her arms...
I'd go, I'd go...
Sail...
Yeah, this is my first stream.
I'm pretty down, eating half gallon of cookie dough ice cream to cure the pain and your singing helps too.
Ah, that sounds really good.
Actually, earlier I really was like, I want a Snickers ice cream bar.
So I think cookie dough ice cream is the right way to go.
Oh, you changed your name back!
I had to put down Pugmug.
No!
Wait, you were Pugmug this whole time?
Teacup!
Oh my god!
Well, welcome back, sadly.
I'm happy that you're back.
I did kind of wonder.
Melodies of life!
OK, that's a good one.
Maybe because I messed up this one.
Maybe I can do...redeem, redeem with melodies of life!
And then this is the last one for real.
Alone, far up...
Oh no.
Wait, I don't have C sharp.
What's equivalent to C sharp?
D flat?
Thank you.
Alone for a while, I've been searching through the...
Wait, what's equivalent to G sharp?
Oh, Jelly, thank you for the raid!
A flat.
Alone for a while...
I can't wait.
Am I getting it wrong?
Searching through the dawn for traces of the love you left inside my lonely heart
To...weave...wait...weave...by...picking up the pieces that remain...melodies...of...a...life...
Love's lost a refrain...
I can't.
I give up.
You know what?
There was no redeeming.
I'm so sorry.
Anyway, thank you guys.
Um, hopefully, hopefully you feel a little bit more relaxed.
If not, um, if not, uh, here, let me, since I sound so close, let me get close.
Uh, wait.
Now I'm gonna even get, I'm gonna get rid of the disc.
Everything.
Goodbye, Omnicore.
Hopefully, hopefully, um, this helped you, um, calm down a little bit, or if you needed it or anything like that, or made you giggle a little bit, maybe.
Sorry.
Okay, good.
I did write practice.
I did write Omnicore practice karaoke, so...
So, hopefully you didn't expect too much, but, um, or maybe you learned about the Omnicore, and if so, that makes me really happy because this is my beloved instrument.
I love this.
I love my Omnicore very much, so...
And, um, yeah, uh, uh, make sure you drink water, okay?
And, um, um, um, things will be okay.
Yeah.
Things will be okay.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
So, uh, have a good night.
Take it easy.
You know, be kind to yourself, and spoil yourself a little bit today, if you need it.
Like, uh, get a Snickers ice cream.
Because I couldn't.
Okay.
I didn't have an intro, so I'm not gonna have an outro.
I'm just gonna go...